Transcriptor: Malena GP
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
Observemos por un momento,
la siguiente tabla.
Si tomamos la altura y la edad,
yo tendría más o menos unos cinco años.
Hola, mi nombre es Megumi Cardona,
soy artista visual y tengo 25 años.
Esta tabla la tomé
del manual de museografía,
que habla de cómo deben ir dispuestas
las obras en un espacio de exposición,
como la galería o los museos.
Este manual habla de
una altura promedio colombiana,
de un metro con cincuenta centimetros,
donde deben ir dispuestas las obras.
Esta medida nos deja a muchos por fuera,
sin poder ver la exposición o incluso,
solamente viendo el reflejo de la luz
en el vidrio de la obra.
Cuando tenía cinco años, recuerdo que
jugaba con mis primos a las escondidas.
Uno de ellos empezaba a contar y
todos salíamos corriendo a escondernos.
Unos se escondían detrás de las cortinas,
otros se escondían debajo de la cama.
Pero yo tenía un lugar especial
en el closet de mi cuarto,
de unos 30 por 30 centímetros.
Allí me escondía y después
de un largo tiempo,
salía por miedo a que no me encontraran.
Incluso todavía estuviera allí .
Después de eso,
la dinámica del juego era diferente.
Mis primos empezaron a buscar en lugares
donde no podría haber un cuerpo,
como la nevera, los cajones de la cocina
o incluso la lavadora.
Yo siempre he habitado el espacio
de una manera distinta.
Este siempre ha sido muy grande, a veces
inalcanzable u otras veces invisible,
como mi reflejo en los espejos
de los baños.
A la inversa de
Alicia en el país de las Maravillas,
cuando ella es muy grande para la casa.
O tal vez la casa, muy pequeña para ella.
Cuando entré a la carrera de Artes,
tenía una clase de dibujo anatómica.
Esta clase consistía en que llegábamos,
disponíamos nuestro papel en el caballete
y comenzamos a dibujar una modelo
que separaba la mitad del salón.
Empezábamos a dibujarle sus proporciones,
sus curvas, sus medidas,
y esta dinámica se repetía
durante todo el semestre.
Así que al finalizar, yo ya sabía
como dibujar un cuerpo promedio.
Una de estas clases
nos pusieron un trabajo,
era crear dos cuerpos
de proporciones distintas,
una de proporciones alargadas
y otra de proporciones más cortas,
con más gravedad.
El de proporciones alargadas
se me hizo mucho más fácil,
llegué a mi casa,
cogí cinco fragmentos de papel
y empecé con tinta litográfica
a dibujarlo.
Me salió más o menos en media hora,
pero el de proporciones más cortas
fue mucho más difícil.
Después de hacer tantos bocetos
y buscar referentes, no me salía nada.
Faltando unos días para la entrega,
estaba revisando mi celular,
en la galería de fotos y me di cuenta que,
había una foto que no había tomado yo,
sino mi mamá en una cita médica.
Y era yo sentada en una silla,
con las manos un poco incómodas,
con una especie de máquina
frente a la cara,
llena de perillas, números, lentes.
Y ahí me di cuenta de que yo era
esa persona de proporciones más cortas.
Entonces llegué a la clase,
mostré el dibujo y pensaba que irónico
hubiese sido llegar con las manos vacías
o incluso haber llegado
con un personaje inventado,
cuando el principal referente había sido
yo durante todos estos años
y no me había dado cuenta.
Ese fue el primer autorretrato que comenzó
el proceso de introspección.
Empecé a dibujarme en espacios cotidianos,
en espacios en lo que yo creía limitantes.
Pero acá tengo una pregunta y es:
¿el cuerpo el discapacitado
o es el espacio el discapacitador?
Una persona en silla de ruedas
no tendría problemas
de poder movilizarse
en diferentes lugares,
si todo hubiese estado lleno de rampas o
tal vez una persona invidente,
podría llegar a todos lados,
si hubiesen guías en el suelo.
O incluso yo podría alcanzar
todos los lugares
si el espacio estuviese adaptado
para mi cuerpo.
Para mí, el dibujo siempre ha sido
la forma de poder observar
y poder observarme a mí.
En otra de estas clases de dibujo,
nos tocó recrear El hombre de Vitruvio,
a modo de que tomábamos seis pliegos
de papel, los poníamos en el piso.
Debíamos acostarnos
y marcar nuestro contorno,
empezando que no tuve que utilizar
seis pliegos de papel, sino solamente dos.
Empecé a marcar mi contorno,
y buscar comparaciones
con diferentes medias del cuerpo,
buscando lo que era
la medida perfecta.
Comparé la planta del pie con la palma
de la mano, la cabeza con el torso.
Y mientras hacía todo este proceso, me di
cuenta de que nada coincidía con nada.
Que esa medida perfecta no la iba
a encontrar en mi cuerpo.
Que yo tenía mi propia medida.
Así que a modo de la anterior clase,
empecé a dibujarme
porque me había dado cuenta
que a pesar de estar 23 años conmigo,
no sabía cómo era.
Tomé el caballete, dispuse el papel y
empecé a dibujar las proporciones,
las curvas, los pliegues,
me di cuenta que no era
esa persona tan monstruosa que creía,
que no había querido ver porque
me veía reflejada en los demás.
Como cuando los niños me preguntan
que por qué soy así.
Y yo les respondo que fue que no me tomé
la sopa cuando estaba chiquita.
Para mí, el dibujo fue ese momento
o ese medio para poder verme.
Para poder hacer una reflexión acerca de
mi cuerpo y como habita el espacio,
y como habitan los espacios también
los demás conmigo.
Así que quería mostrar cómo era habitar y
vivir en un espacio a 110 centímetros.